the storm which veered west overnight as
Lonnie said makes made landfall as a
category 5 in Cuba and ended up going
farther inland than initially expected
this is what it looked like on the
island regardless of where you are in
Florida that forecast has the entire
entire state basically on watch let's go
now to Miami where Jeff Glor leads our
storm preparation coverage Jeff Anthony
good morning - and we are seeing the
first bands here the wind has increased
significantly here just recently we have
not seen significant rain yet but what
we do see are ever-present lightning
strikes in the background the leading
edge of Emma here coming in there is a
sense of tension all across South
Florida that you can see and and frankly
feel right now here in Miami many stores
and homes have been boarded up most have
left this area some have taken shelter
in the Greater Miami area miami-dade
County also Broward County we've spoken
to some people who are not leaving they
don't feel comfortable leaving their
homes they feel like they've made the
preparations that they need to make and
they're hunkering down for this storm as
we've been reporting
irma is a category 4 right now projected
to make landfall in southwest florida
sometime tomorrow it is expected to move
up that west coast of Florida as Lonnie
mentioned and then as you mentioned take
aim at the city of Naples a metro area
of more than 300,000 Jonathan Vigliotti
is there this morning Jonathan good
morning to you Jeff good morning and the
wind has picked up the lightning has
also picked up but it's not the wind
that's the big concern here on the west
coast where we are in Collier County
along the coast of Naples it is that
storm surge and predictions now anywhere
from 6 feet to 12 feet possibly of water
to give you a sense I'm about 6 feet
give or take an inch or two we're
talking twice my height and water and I
want to show you the first line of
defense here these sand dunes if you can
even call them a defense and look at
what's on the other side of them this is
a very familiar scene for miles
on this coast homes like this and take a
closer look at this home what's missing
what don't you see
shudders you don't even see any plywood
here and this isn't an isolated case
I've been traveling throughout the
afternoon and evening yesterday and I
could only count on my hand how many
shudders I saw on homes you have to keep
in mind earlier this week the West Coast
thought they were going to be spared the
brunt of this storm that obviously
changed yesterday this is a community
mainly of snowbirds people that come
down over the winter break and also
retirees but there's also a vibrant
year-round population I spoke with one
gentleman just about a block away from
where we are right now last night he was
actually considering staying here riding
out the storm with his wife but once he
saw that surge estimate he decided it
was time to seek higher ground let me
just move you north because there is an
island that's very important here I
think it's gonna be critical in this
storm it's called Sanibel Island
it is a sliver of sand about 40 miles up
this coast there are homes there I spoke
with one man last night who lives one of
those homes he says that his neighbors
are coming to his home and they're gonna
ride this storm out I asked him if he
was crazy and he said listen we know
that these windows are gonna break we
know that we're likely gonna get
flooding but we are going to stay put I
should mention he has an 87 year old
neighbor that is staying with him police
are saying at this point any area under
mandatory evacuation like much of the
coast and certainly Sanibel those people
that ride out this storm that don't
choose to leave safety security and
police may not be able to get to them in
time in case of an emergency
Jeff Jonathan thank you very much